monsieur le président durant le long
combat que vous avez menées pour
l'émancipation de la tunisie vous êtes
toujours montré fidèle à vous même et
j'aimerais vous demander aujourd'hui
quels sont les grands principes qui ont
guidé votre action la force du parti
réside en contact avec le peuple
c'est en élevant le niveau du peuple
nous faisons de comprendre ses droits le
jeu
le sens de la dignité le sens de l'homme
c'est ce contact continuel par la bouche
la voit pas et non pas simplement par
les journaux comment j'y suis venu avec
mon auto je vais une auto 6 6 1 dans
tout le tuer salle toute la tunisie dans
tous les recoins dans les montagnes je
pars dans des plaines dans le sud dans
le nord
c'était un travail extraordinaire c'est
comme ça que j'ai formé le peuple et que
j'écris ce vaste sentiment d'affection
de gratitude d'espoir qu'au voyait
partout seulement de bourguiba
parce que j'ai circulé dans tout le pays
sans aucune autorisation
la réaction du gouvernement quand elle
en avait assez
c'est de m'envoyer l'espoir en exil de
l'esprit ou en prison
eh bien je continuais l'espoir mon
travail quand je sors de prison de
l'exil ogden de trois ans c'est pour
reprendre mais n'est ce pas mais pour
l'apa grand monsieur le président votre
premier voyage officiel
oui j'aimerais vous demander comment
vous le concevez ce que c'est le
couronnement de toute votre oeuvre
où est-ce que c'est au contraire une
nouvelle impulsion que vous les donner à
au bon rapport entre la
c'est un peu les deux à la fois
cinquante années venue des spas mais
comme cette leclerc avait pour but
justement de nous permettre de coopérer
d'élever le niveau du peuple l'espoir de
sortir du sous développement n'est ce
pas eh bien la france s'est toujours
trouvé là pour nous aider
de sorte que mon voyage c'est pour moi
un couronnement et pour nos deux pays
le renforcement des liens économiques
culturels pour les liens possibles
imaginables militaire n'avons plus nous
n'avons plus de deux complexes
j'aime et j'ai combattu un demi siècle
sans n est ce pas parce que j'ai été
formé mais un peu à la française j'ai
connu les facultés françaises lycées dix
fois les écoles et mr leur horizon et
leurs élèves les ont beaucoup de plus
haut lorsque vous considérez le long
chemin parcouru par la tunisie et que
vous faites le point de sa situation
actuelle
quels sont les problèmes prioritaires
qui vous apparaissent delvaux et la fin
de la lutte
nous avons commencé ce que nous avons
appelé la grande lutte estimant que la
lutte pour l'indépendance
c'est une petite lutte la grande lutte
la lutte pour le développement
c'est la lutte pour élever le niveau du
bac pour sortir du sous développement
pour rattraper allez il faut civiliser
qui ont leur industrie qui on offre
quelle culture le science c'est pour ça
que nous avons donné un grand grand
crédit n'est ce pas pour l'instruction
la france vous a aidé une très grande
mesure c'est concerne les professeurs
les instituteurs et nous savons
maintenant des cadres valables
nous n'avions même pas n'est ce pas de
cadres obtenir mise par l'administration
non je suis optimiste quand on parle de
la tunisie d'après le bol du match de
dix mois je crois que j'ai fait quelque
chose de solide qui tiendra appelez moi